tiene il serpente
c'è un toro giunto
anche un bel mi ascolti sottoporci
benvenuti solita spesso oggi nuovissimo
tocca appena uscita su un nuovissimo
gioco di robles e non ho pescato e
questa volta saremo nel far west end nel
deserto con i cowboy e capaci vedete ma
siamo dei banditi in una maglietta
sei una bandita ricercato ma io voglio
che i capelli la mia maglietta
vabbè comunque abbiamo già il cappello
da cowboy
bandana c'è qualcuno qui tra l'altro un
bandito come noi è più piccolo però vede
signora cosa sta succedendo io non so
niente di tutto ciò che è appena uscito
ma sembra beigua ma ammette stiamo
dentro a una prigione prigione sì è vero
stiamo dei bambini dobbiamo dovremmo
scappare dalla prigione del vecchio west
allora qui ci sono delle reti le
serrature che sono bloccate però trovare
la chiave guarda qui una chiave maggiore
di dottore lento a per far muro quindi
dobbiamo cercare di portare l'attenzione
della guardia e rubarle la chiave
proviamo a salire a qui sul letto se non
avete ancora la state un mi piace
lasciatemi parametro presenti 32
io provo a scappare lascia sotto ciao
ma come è possibile che nella prigione
dimenticherà di questo buco in cui si
può scappare boh che bello se volete
certo siamo qui c'è il saloon
questo è il bar dei banditi vediamo come
voglio esplorare tutto si è certo anche
il bar
guarda sussurrando il pianoforte
perché progetti non c'è nessun suono no
ma si cercherà non ho mangiato o
c'è qualcosa di strano forse fa per
arrivare una tempesta aspetta di stabia
3 di qua però vedi c'è qualcuno qui
certo è che io cerco un cavallo così
facciamo più veloce è attento a non
cadere dei barili e dai barili
questa è la prigionia dove siamo usciti
se non si può rientrare attentando
sfracellati che bello essere nel deserto
come doveste come mai non si tempora
sfracellato quante volte perché lo hai
appena detto mi sono sfracellato nelle
sabbie mobili che ti ho detto
ecco vitale questo cappello da cowboy by
sono l'unica se lo mangia
copriti lui no si sono caduta ma non mi
succede niente guarda che strano adesso
sprofondi nelle sappiamo
domeniche
cambio mobili che non cade nella sabbia
perché sono sappiamo bene già me lo sono
accorto si legge nell'articolo è
risucchiato non ci credo che è vitale mi
ha superato deve raggiungerlo dove
abbiamo detto non lo so perché ma quella
quello no anche a me è successo non lo
so bene utili anche dentro questi quel
piccolo tono dei carrelli per il
trasporto delle sabbie mobili
perché mio fratello perché sai perché
perché le sabbie sono mobili guidati il
carrello per noi sappiamo bene
sembra di essere male ci credono in una
schiappa dicevo sembra di essere in
indiana jones
il cappello va beh non ci credo e
incredibile in queste skype l'umanità si
sta sfracellando più volte digitale
allora
e difficilissimo capito il trucco
bisogna andare piano
ma tu sei ancora lì arriva davanti
cavani 6 no io sono dietro di noi
insegnerò bisogna saltare sui bordi stai
attenta
ok prima superato
salta sempre che il mare sia riuscita ma
non ci perdo ma vediamo quale è vitale
tra quelle sono quello che è quello che
la voglia di te dalla gli diamo
partecipate a cadere nelle sabbie allora
sono l'unico che è sopravvissuto qui
tutti gli altri sono caduti allora
vediamo il primo saltati poi dai puoi
farcela non giocherà la coppia
lasciate un mi piace per portare fortuna
a vitale vediamo lasciatemi piace dinamo
e vediamo se ha funzionato il vostro mi
piace vediamo
se l'utente non tanto in tanto
l'ultimo dai tutto cambiato non
facciamo fatto ogni anno ora che
dobbiamo qui
danno alcuno è accaduto non mi dire che
devi iniziare tutto da capo
abbiamo meno male cosa di strano in
queste scale non riesco a salire bene
ecco ei e ora bisogna salire a qua sopra
pur se l'ho fatto è
davvero difficile saltare qui
sei riuscito a cadere
sono riuscito sostituite è viva e ora
una chiesetta fa c'è anche un cimitero
wow quindi non so dovremo entrare qua no
qui è chiuso e dove devo andare in
montagna sì ho capito ma vola sopra
guarda o no dove dovevo capire la guerra
c'è una scala franken india vediamo c'è
un'altra scala 6 di campanile
bello ma
vediamo vitali che serve
credo che questa sia dinamite è questa
che cos'è allora è un appello che
consentiranno e allora bisogna salire su
questioni nato per farsi trasportare da
questi buttata ha detto eppure dove
dovuto al tar e
attento e molto difficile qua devi stare
attento ok va bene e sappiamo
quando non cadere giù ma da abolire
ce l'ho fatta non si credono dai puoi
farcela sono caduto anna capitale
attento erano tronista non cadere vai
vai vai
wow ma dobbiamo andare di qua qua
wow bravo attento quando non toccare
quella contenere il petrolio petrolio
tep attento che dobbiamo saltare sui
cactus e sulla dinamica
peccato che non l'ho visto progettarsi
da
si è scatenata qualcun altro però
pure tu anch'io mi sono sorge lato nella
stessa commento e steve room sembrava
facile ma non è facile
felicità ce l'ho fatta qua c'è la
miniera d'oro vorrei che aspetto così
andiamo a sieve
eccoli in casa non ce l'ha fatta dice la
16 a volta che ha fatto ascoltare
maniero d'oro salto ecco mi alzavo per
uno che si muove invece no dobbiamo
andare noi
ma c'era la ruta aielli e forse di
riprendere più rincorsa
fidiamo
[Risate]
quindi qua il pavimento è la barca che
figo giorno
è
come andare così veloce che sono bravo
de ski forum è vero ma
dove sei guardate
ma perché mi porti sempre sfortuna ogni
partita guardate vitale portiamo vitale
come cade caso
dove sei tu dietro di te
raggiungendo wow il ponte c'è un perso
30 giga
non ero io non ero io che cari attento
potrebbe morte che cos'è non è una cosa
abbiamo fatto ma sentiamo su i teschi
attento devi solo saltare sui testi non
su quella cosa verde il culo serpente ok
rivestite europei sono divertenti
simpatici attento sì sì insomma qui
dietro di te ne passare da sotto forse
si può passare da
8mp bella portarena sopra ok allora sono
qui su questo tracciato del wow i
lingotti d'oro sono caduto giovedì e noi
dobbiamo stare sui lingotti d'oro
dobbiamo andare adoro moquette bella
skype room proprio l'ambientazione
indiana jones alla ci sono qualcuno si è
sfracellato no anch'io mi sono speso
lavori ci sono degli scorpioni di la
testa bisogna andare dall'altro lato è
vaio a destra è vero quella era una
trappola mancare di la merda vive di
essi livello di lavorare anche bene tifo
e problemi chiamati frutti
o
almeno non si muovono si muoverà
perdendo camminano
[Musica]
via
oggi superati e come faccia saltare fino
alla
vediamo vitale
si ricordi e anche tu forse non è questa
la strada sia quella perché vedi che c'è
la freccia dietro non esser pente e giù
ci aspetta la bocca del serpente o no
dice che ci mangeranno di sé lecite
che ha rischiato ancora no ok nel
serpentara
allora sapete ha mangiato delle uova
rumore bova gusci di uova ok sono
riuscito a passare aspetta però qui c'è
qualcos'altro che
cosa sono queste cose bella forza c'è un
osso beh dopo tutto è un serpente
gigante quindi ha mangiato un po di
qualcosa di gigante aspetta che cosa
penso che bisogna passare quando ali si
toglie questa cosa
già fatta
strumenti come i vasi sanguigni del
serpente non lo so ha detto oppure rai
raggi laser che sono all'interno del
serpente di nazareth ok allora vedevo
sembra siamo tornati fuori del deserto
c'è un nuovo gigante
no ma l'ambientazione bellissima guarda
ci sarò anche di quelle ventole per i
mulini a vento qui che come si chiamano
voglio restare qua a fare il como e anzi
la cavo però la stazione di tutto c'è un
toro giunto mia me anche a me e mi ha
spedito di porci
come da mandare adesso con il toro qui
no io voglio vedere vitale che vola
accaduta del toro dai no no no può
imparare mi dai un bacio cosa
mi ha fatto volare
cosa hai fatto è il tono mi ha colpito
me ero seduta qua ok è di questa sedia
quindi mi sono salvata ok prova ad
affrontare il toro di nuovo
ha fatto volare anche te
beh ovviamente essendo dei cowboy
dovevamo affrontare un thor certo
aiuto ok qua sopra
è preso
e bisogna stare superate
e forse ancora non mi ha visto
ok non milanista che ho visto allora
però qua non può raggiungermi quindi
devo salire forse di un brano meglio
domani
se non riusciremo sono riuscito a
salvare il tetto
io ce l'ho fatto attento sul tetto dopo
lo può prendermi beh ti aspetto alla
transaction ma tu come i patti perché io
sono troppo bravo devo saltare dignità e
ce la puoi fare ciò può fare vedere io
d'ora militari
siamo però è stato da solo ma tu dove
sei sei sul tetto
ad hoc è troppo bello
il treno sta andando per sta
attraversando il deserto l'ufficio c'è
uno scoppio gigante è sì mi vogliono
esserci capasso
mamma mia è bruttino devo ricominciare
tutto daccapo non ci credo tv
riaffrontare il toro o no food ruby tale
tu sei riuscito a passare
ti ho attraversato lo scorpione ma si
sono un sacco di altri ostacoli tipo il
petrolio e petrolio è capitano è
riuscito a tornare non cadere nello
scorpione circolando e come allora devo
saltare su questi barili di petrolio si
ok avanti ci sono sembra di essere in un
film western sveglia ne so
[Applauso]
che cosa sono queste andare la somma
deve evitare di dover iniziare tutto da
capo o no tra cui sono avanti vi sono
pure il carbone dai ti aspetto ma testi
si strugge l'area è pietro così
difficili
wow sono voluti va sbrigati
eccomi
altro carbone
no
a como
ei qualcuno mi ha salutato gestito ciao
nì tese sfracellato papa non ci credo
perché è così difficile
ok con cavani piano piano chiaro
aspetta non potevo andare di brava si è
meglio
ha detto devo cercare di non cadere ed
altre ci sei quasi deve saltare nella
locomotiva adesso
ce l'ho fatta e ora scendi giu ha vinto
il primo winslet si
muova da lì
siamo qui a che cosa servono queste un
calo bloccato
[Musica]
perché siamo in piedi sul cavallo
ma dove possiamo darla siamo un
capannello tutte le scrivo un po il
cavallo che non cade nelle sabbie mobili
c9 di
navigata facciamo però a salire sulle
scale qui col cavallo
bellissimo che hanno questo punto cavani
mi sono bloccato nelle sabbie mobili
così bello sono comodi aspettati
raggiungo ei è pronta facciamo una gara
che aspetta partiamo da partinico dove
unità non sa guidare il cavallo c'era la
patente eccovi
una gara dobbiamo arrivare al alla
locomotiva rotta del treno carina per
primo vince va bene 32 una via
dove vita
non c'è una stanza ma io non ti vedo
tutto prima vista
sentiamo insultare roma il cavallo one
si sale sul treno ovviamente il
bello è stata troppo
sapendo che lo stato mi piace per
vederne altri scriveteci nei commenti il
vostro momento preferito è ora vi lascio
4 verso il leader cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video il capito quello che
preferite
ciao